Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Kathryn Judge, who's the Harvey J. Goldschmidt,
professor of law at Columbia Law School and
also author of the book Direct The Rise of
the Middlemen Economy and the Power of Going
to the Source. It's really great having you
on. I appreciate your time.
Speaker 3: Yeah, thank you for having me.
Speaker 1: So I think intuitively many in
our audience will understand the concept of
middlemen in the global economy. And my instinct
is that at some point it was quite logical
to start seeing middlemen as we started to
see many industries scale international trade.
Know we could think of reasons why why it
made sense. What are the origins of so many
middlemen in so many of the industries with
which we regularly engage?
Speaker 3: I mean, you really hit on a lot
of the drivers for the the middlemen or the
connectors through whom good flow through
money flows from people who have it to those
who need it. And both as the economy got more
global, but also as it got more specialized.
We saw a proliferation of middlemen helping
to facilitate those transfers. So you might
have, you know, investors with excess capital
in one country and limited opportunities for
return. And so you ended up initially as one
and then subsequently oftentimes layers of
middlemen that would help facilitate flows
to where there might be productive undertakings,
even if that meant kind of going moving the
money abroad. Similarly, in production, we
know games from trade is a is a classic idea.
And of course, we've had a shift from just
having goods imported from one country to
another to really having globalized supply
chains where goods are made in a multi continent
undertaking with each step kind of undertaking
what it can do most efficiently. But of course,
as you have that disaggregation of production,
you need middlemen to help connect each step
along the way.
Speaker 1: So before we talk about some of
the downsides, I mean, it seems accurate to
say that in many cases, consumers do see lower
prices on many products as a result of middlemen.
Is that fair?
Speaker 3: That's certainly fair. And one
of the points of the book is actually middlemen
usually arise because they're really providing
significant value. And it explores how overcoming
the informational and logistical challenges
that can otherwise impede transactions that
make everybody better off is a real value
enhancing service to provide. So middlemen
themselves are at this point really the backbone
of the economy that we're not going to go
anywhere soon with. The book explores is in
a static environment you can look at take
a snapshot and it looks like they're providing
a lot of value and oftentimes they are. But
the very nature of what makes them so good
at their jobs also gives them the ability
to exercised outsized influence on the evolution
of the market and the evolution of the laws
that are governing the spaces where they're
active that sometimes allows them to extract
more value and and lead to potentially other
challenges in future periods.
Speaker 1: So and when you say that because
if I think of like Walmart and Amazon, Walmart
and Amazon are middlemen in a sense, in that
they don't manufacture most of the products
they sell. So in a sense, they've created
this marketplace very convenient for all sorts
of different products, but they also will
contract with other middlemen in many cases
as well. So so they both are middlemen and
also are not depending on which relationship
we're thinking of.
Speaker 3: Yeah. And one of the interesting
point is when you look at the term middleman
itself is very easy to define in the abstract.
But when you're trying to imply that a particular
company is part of what you realize is a lot
of middlemen, do you provide additional value
along the way? So the primary role might be
helping to overcome informational or logistical
challenges, but oftentimes they're doing other
things in the process, right. And so the goal
is to say, look, that's not going to ever
be a line. But conceptually, it's helpful
to understand companies that are primarily
engaged in this business of connecting and
Amazon and Walmart are among them. They certainly
have other activities that they engage in.
Amazon, with something like Amazon Web Services,
is providing a completely different type of
value proposition. But much of what they do
is make it so American consumers can very
readily access and have enough information
to trust to buy goods that were made on the
other side of the world. So there's efficiencies
there and there's a real connection that's
provided. But there's drawbacks.
Speaker 1: One of the things that I think
is a concern for many in my audience, from
the things we've talked about, is the ways
in which sometimes very large corporations
will use middlemen and or contractors to avoid
accountability, in some cases, sometimes point
the finger at some other entity. The Amazon
delivery services is one where often the vans
that we all see driving around are not actually
owned and operated by Amazon. Even if they
have Amazon painted. Sometimes it's local
LLC delivery companies that own a bunch of
vans or, you know, there's different things.
Is this one of the concerns with this infrastructure
where you have all of these different parties?
Speaker 3: It is one of those very significant
concerns. So part of the challenge is, you
know, if you're just going directly to the
creator of a good not only there's a relationship
there, but there's clear accountability and
any information you want about that good,
you can readily ascertain by asking the person
or asking for representations and warranties
if you want to be legalistic about the the
product, but also about the nature of how
it was made and who was impacted. And part
of what the book shows is that much of the
complexity of today's supply chains and the
structure of these layers of intermediaries
grew up at a time where we just assume investors
wanted to maximize the risk adjusted returns,
and consumers wanted nothing more than the
lowest price good holding quality constant
according to some objective measures. But
now we're in a world where people suddenly
realize the government can't solve all of
our problems. We actually care more about
the impact of the goods on the planet, on
the workers, and all through intentional use
of of middlemen to to gate, but also just
a byproduct of really complex chains that
we're not necessarily designed to create opacity.
But as a practical matter, have created that
opacity. It is now virtually impossible at
times to understand. I mean, you can look
at your breakfast cereal and trying to figure
out where it all came from is oftentimes beyond
the average consumers capability. And so as
we're bringing these additional values that
enable the accountability that people now
want is oftentimes very difficult, if not
impossible to glob on top of the current system.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, in the kind of like
hipster lefty space that I occupy, there's
been a big move in the last five years to
go towards, you know, craft and independent
producers and products that are not as widely
available. Sometimes that in and of itself
is what makes them more interesting. And and
I do think that there is value to that because,
you know, if you think about, like the coffee
roasting industry, instead of going to your
grocery store and grabbing the, you know,
a leg row that's available nationally or whatever,
you find some local roaster and it's more
interesting and you know who's roasting it,
but it's almost always more expensive. And
so it it does seem that there is a very clear
advantage, at least in the minds of consumers
to that. But there is certainly a price associated
with it.
Speaker 3: Yeah, as I want to say a couple
of things on that. So first, I love the coffee
roasting example. When I examples my box is
Reese Roasters, which was a local coffee roaster,
you know, and I knew them when they were small
and they kept growing. But it is really nice.
And one of the nice things about going direct
is even though it's more expensive, you not
only learn a lot, but you know where the money's
going. So I actually feel a little better
about the money I'm spending because I know
the company. I know it's a local business.
I know all of the people involved. I know
how they treat their employees. So so I actually
feel better about the money I spent. And that
is partly shifting from a world where we had
long assumed scarcity to one where as a practical
matter, even though we still have a scarcity
mindset because that's how we're taught to
think so often we really live in a world of
abundance. So making more selective choices
is oftentimes more rewarding, which is part
of why you're seeing the trends you are. The
final point I would make is even though that's
very often true, that right now direct is
a little bit of a privilege. Good or seems
like a privilege. Good? Yeah. It's more pervasive
than people realize outside of cities. So
I get this question all the time from people
who live in relatively urban environments.
I live in an urban environment, but right
now about our country. And part of what's
been interesting since I published the book
is I'm hearing from people in South Carolina
and Ohio in all of these different states
where they say this is exactly what's already
happening in my community. And actually, they're
they're keeping all of the value in the community.
They're not necessarily paying as much as
a premium because it's not the craft artisan
that we think about in Brooklyn or or kind
of like a a neighborhood as much as somebody
who's really just like trying to create make
additional money by doing a product or service
on the side and maintains competitive by having
good prices. It's to be as cheap as the mass
produce good in Wal-Mart, partly because they're
you're exploiting kind of these incredibly
low wage and worker protections in other places.
But you really can. I think he hit a broader
set of the value spectrum that many of us
appreciate.
Speaker 1: When it comes to supply chain and
some of the issues that we saw early in the
pandemic and then sort of again and then even
now to some degree, and we've seen baby formula
and different things. It's not completely
obvious to me as someone who does not share
your level of expertize in this issue, whether
the problem was made worse or was actually
resolved more quickly by the kind of status
quo of many middlemen in terms of supply chains
and the way that products kind of get to the
shelves and ultimately into people's homes.
What is the relationship or the connection
between those supply chain issues we've seen
over the last three years and the existence
of middlemen?
Speaker 3: So I would say in terms of the
the risk, what we've seen arise, it really
can be traced back to the proliferation of
middlemen. But even the middlemen, as you
point out, I think, accurately played a role
in helping us to address the challenges. Part
of what the direct documents is the way middlemen
proliferated slowly in number two become more
layered in ways that really created these
complex ecosystems. And generally speaking,
nobody took a step back to look at the entire
complex ecosystem. They were thinking, we
can eke a little more cost savings here, a
little more efficiency there. And so they
kept making decisions that incrementally were
small but in aggregate transform the nature
of the system. And then, as we saw, once there
were shifts, whether it is making demand or
or limitations of supply, because countries
of origins, you know, were facing shutdowns.
There were ripple effects that magnified that
original distortion because you had all of
these suddenly individual players that had
depended on the system working well, having
to figure out how to signal, you know, what
they wanted, what they needed in ways where
they really looking out for themselves. And
so you suddenly ended up with people wanting,
demanding for more than they actually needed
because they're trying to hoard. And really,
the distortions kept getting bigger. And what's
interesting and for me is that this was actually
one of the original motivations for the book.
A lot of my original work was on financial
regulation and looking at the way securitization
chains that proliferated in the early aughts
contributed to the oh seven and oh eight crisis.
And we saw the exact same thing there where
we saw these chains that grew. So they were
capital supply chains as opposed to good supply
chains. But they grew incrementally over time.
They appeared to make credit more available
so more people could buy homes. And it seemed
like a really good thing at the time because
we could suddenly tap in to these new pools
of capital in Germany and Japan to fund American
homes. But we created an incredibly complex
ecosystem where once things broke down a little,
the dysfunction magnified and nobody had the
information they needed to help stabilize
the functioning.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it seems there's this interesting
example I remember from early in the pandemic
related to toilet paper where, as you say,
people started wasn't that people were using
more in total, but they were buying more,
meaning they would be stocked up for a longer
period of time. And it was shifting from being
at work to being at home. And one of the questions
a lot of people were asking was, well, all
of the companies that deliver paper goods
to businesses, shouldn't they just be able
to redirect that and put it in grocery stores
or at CVS or whatever the case may be? And
part of the explanation was, well, we're talking
about different packaging. These things are
not packaged for sale in the same way. And
that's done much earlier in the supply chain,
often before it gets to the middlemen, the
local company that that you go to. Also sometimes
like the toilet paper rolls for businesses
are gigantic, you know, and it just doesn't
work at home. But also the companies doing
the servicing office buildings don't have
any connection whatsoever to like CVS or Staples
or whatever. So there were really a whole
bunch of things that would have had to change.
Now, would it have been simpler if the toilet
paper manufacturers dealt directly with everyone?
I don't know. That would have had its own
share of problems.
Speaker 3: Yeah. And part of the book is really
not saying direct is the solution. As much
as direct is the cornerstone. And a cornerstone
really is a very, very small piece of a much
larger, larger edifice. So the point is saying
we've gotten to this hyper intermediated world
where generally speaking, the instinct was
always to add additional layers of middlemen.
But as you nicely point out earlier, there's
already a countermovement underway. There's
already a number of people saying to be able
to really get what I want, to have my values
match my actions. I need to opt out of the
system entirely. And so by documenting both
the growth of this hyper intermediated world
and this revolution, well, then we can figure
out how to navigate this territory in between.
And the toilet paper is a great example of
it. So as you're pointing out, the nature
of the supply chains had incredible rigidities,
which just meant like they were used to doing
one thing and they couldn't easily change.
Right. And oftentimes what we're seeing with
those rigidities, the complexity really accentuates
them. And it's not about going direct, but
having fewer middlemen and shorter chains
can oftentimes enhance resilience and enhance
flexibility. So trying to figure out where
did we add layers over time without anybody
really understanding, well, what are the needs
of the world where things might go wrong and
where that might create problems? Or going
back to our earlier conversation, where there
might be a lack of accountability, because
now there's just no way for us to actually
see through all of the different layers involved.
Speaker 1: There are some industries where
there's been a move into a more direct model.
One of the ones I think is interesting is,
you know, for me, the experience of. Going
to car dealers has never been good. I mean,
it's just it's not a pleasant experience.
Very low satisfaction with it for the average
consumer. I ordered my last car online. It's
a Tesla. I didn't have to talk to anybody.
I picked the features I wanted. There was
no negotiation. And then I got a call when
the car was ready and it was a dramatically
better experience. Now, this is all aside
from all the other concerns about Elon Musk's
tweets, all these different things, I get
that. But as an experience, the dealership
is a terrible experience and it seems to me
that it would only make the end product more
expensive. One report says on average, people
pay about 1200 dollars more for vehicles than
they otherwise would because of the dealership
experience. Another one that as many real
estate agents that I have in my social circle
that I think could be eliminated is the idea
that a realtor regularly takes, you know,
a slice out of every real estate transaction,
can sell the same house multiple times. In
many countries, you just deal with a lawyer
and you don't need the entire infrastructure
of the real estate agent. You could potentially
cut out a middleman. Can you talk about either
of those industries and or other industries
that have done well at moving to a more direct
model?
Speaker 3: So both absolutely outstanding
examples. I spent a lot of time on residential
real estate and the car market fits equally
well. And I'd actually done a huge amount
of research and only left it out because I
had so many other great examples. Yeah. So
the great thing about your Tesla example is,
yes, it was a better experience and contrary
to our earlier conversation, it was cheaper.
You're cutting out an expensive middleman
and you're saving real money. And same thing
in residential real estate. We know for your
average middle class family, the median family,
United States, they don't have most of their
money in stocks and bonds. Housing is our
number one source of wealth. So in real estate,
agents come in and take 5% and average. Even
now of every single real estate transaction,
you're eating directly out of the bottom line,
the nest egg of your typical middle class
family in a very meaningful way.
Speaker 1: Now, many of the real estate agents
in their defense are also middle class, right?
I mean, there's two sides to that, to be fair.
Speaker 3: Yeah. The hard thing with a real
estate agent is there's some really good research
just showing that we have too many of them.
So they provide very real value, but it's
relatively easy to become a real estate agent.
So what we've seen is there is some great
work showing, you know, comparing, for example,
Minneapolis and Boston and saying, look, when
housing prices were about the same, each agent
sold on average like ten houses a year, 12
houses a year. And then suddenly the Boston
housing market went crazy. So a decade later,
what happened? Real estate agents in Minneapolis
were still selling 10 to 12 houses a year.
Real estate agents in Boston, their income
was about the same, but they were suddenly
selling on average 4 to 5 houses a year. And
that's because. So the commissions went up
because a percentage of sales, so so many
more people became real estate agents. And
then so what do they all do? They send out
like really glossy mailings to people who
already own their homes, just saying, like,
choose me if you're going to sell. So it's
not actually against the real estate agents
themselves. It's a system that doesn't serve
the agents and really doesn't serve homeowners.
Right. And one nice thing about both the car
market and the real estate market is they
are examples where there have been state laws
across numerous states that entrench the current
system. So, for example, if you look at penetration
of electric vehicle sales, one of the most
significant indicators is do you have state
laws that effectively entrench the need to
use a car dealership?
Speaker 1: Doesn't New Jersey have such a
law?
Speaker 3: And I think so. I should double
check, but a number of a number of states
do. And ten states still have things protecting
effectively, effectively prohibiting rebates
because the really for real estate is the
buy side more than the sell side where what
where a lot of countries have managed to get
rid of the agent. So oftentimes sellers need
a little more hand-holding, but you're also
paying a lot to a buyer where they're doing
their own work on Zillow or Redfin. But of
course, what you're really tapping into there
is the MLS, which is still controlled by full
service real estate agents. And so those are
both great examples where when you really
look at the mechanisms, they are layered and
a little complicated. But where you see people
who came in originally and provided value
and then in a post-Internet era where there's
so much more ability for consumers to do things
for themselves, we should have had a change
of the market structure, but the change has
been relatively modest relative to the cost
savings and the alternatives that open up.
And it's partly because the the entrenched
middlemen really do a good job to. To undermine
the the alternatives that otherwise would
be available both through market mechanisms
and through through legal mechanisms.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Justifying their own, their
own existence, essentially. The book is Direct
The Rise of the Middle Man Economy and the
Power of Going to the Source. We've been speaking
with the book's author, Katherine Judge, who
teaches law at Columbia Law School. Thank
you so much for your time today. I really
appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Thank you for having me.